el gobierno alemán no dudó en calificar
de histórico el acuerdo del por éxito
entre la unión europea y reino unido-
asegurando que se logró un objetivo
clave evitar un cambio de año caótico
según indicó el ministro de exteriores
alemán hay comas para las autoridades en
este país
el acuerdo es particularmente importante
desde un punto de vista político pues se
negoció y se concretó durante la
presidencia alemana del consejo europeo
que acaba de terminar y también por
supuesto es muy importante desde una
perspectiva económica pues reino unido
es uno de los principales socios
comerciales de alemania y un destino
clave para las exportaciones de este
país el gobierno alemán quizás habría
querido que el acuerdo tuviera un mayor
componente sobre las relaciones futuras
de más de seguridad o de política
exterior pero igual se mostró confiado
en que servirá de base para las
relaciones futuras relaciones que por
cierto han estado marcadas en los
últimos días por las críticas hacia
merkel de sectores conservadores
británicos explican que no ha habido
confianza entre angela merkel y el
primer ministro británico
boris johnson y que fue el merkel la que
bloqueó intentos anteriores de lograr un
acuerdo en la prensa al conservadora
británica incluso se refiere en américa
el como found line o la señora no cuando
le preguntaron a merkel por ello aquí en
berlín ella explicó de manera muy
concreta que no fue ella la que negoció
el acuerdo y que por el contrario estuvo
siempre en manos de la comisión europea